als wochen highlight was genau im netz
willkommen beim ein video jahr leute ich
auf euch jetzt gut ich weiß wie ich sie
ausschlafen zu gange
ich weiß auf jeden fall stoppen und habe
mir dieses motto und irgendwie die rs4
zu sagen na ja es sei egal da und dort
nicht gehen ich habe heute was echt
krass ist geplant
und ich hab so was auf youtube
eigentlich auch noch nie gesehen
zumindest in deutschland auf jeden fall
war letztens in köln unterwegs und mir
war irgendwie langweilig und ich bin ein
euro shop gegangen aber dann ist mir
folgende idee gekommen so alex du kannst
doch einfach mal irgendwelche produkte
hier kaufen und die vorstellen weil da
gab es platz wo ich das mit kraft es
kostet nur 1 euro viele sachen ihr
folgen könnte wahrscheinlich von der
kirmes weil ihr da irgendwie dann so so
luftballons kaputt macht oder für fünf
euro und dann kriegt dafür irgendeinen
frei und denkt euch so wie ihr es
bestimmt viel mehr kostet nicht mal euro
meistens als ich glaube hier sind echt
sachen verspreche ich mir genau was ich
alles verbockt habe ich hab einfach ein
paar sachen mitgenommen
viele sachen sind echt mega geil okay
was heißt mega geil aber man kann auf
jeden fall einiges mit anfangen für
einen euro also ich glaube wenn ich mit
acht jahren 1 euro shop gewesen dass wir
das paradies für mich gewesen als ich
will eigentlich gar nicht eingeladen ihr
könnt ja gern mal in die kommentare
schreiben ob ich noch meinen teil machen
soll oder einfach nach oben lassen
welcher dann sehen auch im blick gehabt
und jetzt fangen wir an chile tüte
soviel zeit voll auf jeden fall ein
kollege von mir sagen gebt mir jetzt
einfach mal die füße und bekommst du
dann nacheinander irgendetwas daraus
leicht einfach rein und gibt
das müssten erstmal so acht lachen sein
ok wack vergessen abzusagen also im ein
euro shop gibt es jetzt nicht nur
produkte für 1 euro aber ich habe auf
jeden fall geschaut nicht dieser
produkte kostet mehr als zwei euro
stücks war so 71 und ihr werdet merken
kraft so viel zeit gibt es für höchstens
170 album let go big band mit produkt
immer ein
wer kennt diese pistole nicht von der
kirmes aigner kümmern
das dingen dieses ding kostet 1 euro
das heißt wenn die für 5 euro
irgendwelche luftballons auf der kirmes
oder auch im jahr machen wie man das
auch immer nennen will und dann denkt
habe ich aber ein richtig gutes geschäft
gemacht und dieser pistole
nein ich habe natürlich sofort ein
gefragter leute die die teile ging
braucht jetzt auch ganz hinten
[Musik]
es ist gerade leider von dunkel deswegen
muss ich morgen früh das noch einmal
testen und dann draußen und immer
gespannt sie mitteilen fliegen
er war einst selber kurz das ist klar
es ist einfach der richtige mann ist
morgen testen
wieso ist es jetzt für gut gegangen kann
nicht sein dass abgebrochen ist
abgebrochen
ich hole mir jetzt noch mal ich hatte
mal ein zweiter sein ich morgen das fest
und vier messer hält drei tage okay
leute kommen zunächst produkt let's go
einfach eine flöte wir haben ja eine
blockflöte von disney für 50 leute
sitzen auch immer flöte spielen ist das
[Musik]
team gut aber ich sollte meine flöten
karriere fortsetzen als wenn ich schon
immer meine flöte anwalt konnte nur 150
bin ich fasziniert davon schon von
diesem wissen ich habe ich keine ahnung
was da drin ist
ihr könnt ihr könnt ja wahrscheinlich
alle den film medien ich habe mir da
nicht europa aktiv in kostet zwei euro
kostet das teil ist jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt was jetzt einfach mittendrin
[Musik]
als solche mit 62 euro
was solche zensierten alter also ohne
spaß das hier ist mein favorit ist jetzt
sauer ist kaputtgegangen ehrlich
schreibt mich fest hier gar nicht erst
so recht klappte dem ehrlich cook jetzt
geht das wieder unter eigentlichen
wieder nach oben gehen verlor sich alle
servierten alle medien servierten
viel spaß damit und elektro gekommen
zunächst als künftiger das habe ich ganz
an einige fonds zur kasse gegangen bin
vielleicht kennen also von früher das
gab irgendwie an jedem kiosk sondern
jeder tanke zumindest in ähnlich klingen
wenn ich jetzt mal gespannt was passiert
im alter wenn ich schon dieses puder
hier sehe das so geil
schaut euch das mal von dieser roger hat
nicht mal euro gekostet glaube ich
glaube der 50 cent gekostet
das sind so leider hatte ich mal jetzt
passt auf warum gibts sowas im ein euro
shops mit genau wie diese monsterwelle
weißt du diese mine ist diese fällt
jetzt in ein-euro-jobs eingeworfen
herrlich also wenn ihr unter zehn oder
sogar noch zwei dann bringt eure eltern
auf jeden fall dazu mit euch im ein euro
shop zu gehen sagt schöne grüße von
addex und dann wird das was ich tue das
mal kurz zur seite
so sollten wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten produkt als ich das gesehen hat
was ist das ehrlich was ist das was soll
man hier mitmachen meisten das 100 das
war cook auf das sei ein stabiles zimmer
heute ist martina keine ahnung wie man
sowas braucht aber es macht spaß damit
zu spielen ich bin zwar kein hund aber
es geht in die gleiche richtung
okay leute kommen zu einem produkt das
ich habe einfach einen taschenrechner
für 1 euro 50 gefunden ehrlich ich
dachte jeder taschenrechner kostet
mindestens zehn euro oder so immer ein
zurück zu schön mal gespannt wer rechnen
kann
wahrscheinlich wäre jetzt batterien oder
- meine hand du kannst du nicht sagen
das ding kann ich da ist das gar nichts
drin folge steht drauf so lapawa aber er
braucht riesiger des antiken man später
rein tun also leute kauft auf dem
kasseler aus meinen euroshop hat auch
erst mal gucken ob er funktioniert da
geht nur wenn man nicht hin hälfte
funktioniert sogar wie kratzt das ist
nur da muss man denken wie krass die
technik ist immerhin hat die hier in
diesem kleinen dingen computer drin der
das berechnen kann
und du denkst dir ist gar nicht
trainiert nur plastik drin als man sieht
wer kann echt rechnen also für mich ist
das gerade erst hat ich hätte es nicht
wieder und respekt an
wir hatten taschen davon allerdings
wahrscheinlich hat der taschenrechner
oder aber leute vielleicht nur als
kleiner tipp wenn ihr euch diesen
taschenrechner holt nehmt euch auf jeden
fall auch gleich eine taschenlampe mit
weil sonst kommt damit nicht weit
sorry so leute kommen zum nächsten
produkt junge alte das ist das beste
wenn jemals ist das das beste auf der
ganzen vier menschen die zeit ein euro
gekostet ich habe jetzt haben was zu tun
ohne schwarze schmeckt schweiz im
vergleich zu dem seiner eltern war ich
weiß ob und wo will ich hin schmeckt
auch so als hätte nur einen euro kosten
okay leute und eines nach hab ich doch
ein angebot das habe ich gefühl heraus
gegangen bin und das musste ich wirklich
auf jeden fall
wir haben ja eine xxl packt und meldung
also wenn ihr bock auch macht -
abgeleitet dann ein euro jobs um diesen
sogar die leute wir machen kurz shabani
trend wer mehr machen abwechslung so
erstmal dazu ist wieder auf jeden fall
mehr spaß macht es wenn den banken
partners auf jeden fall nach oben da
sektor slapstick und instagram ab ganz
wichtig und wir sehen uns dann morgen
wieder
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen tag
haut rein und